[Music]
so a woman
has been charged after she got surgery
right so she gets uh is getting a mole
removed
she she gets her bill after um the
surgery is over and she sees there's a
charge
and when she looks at the charge she's
like what the [ __ ] is this
and it says brief emotion what the [ __ ]
11
11 oh but she gets a discount so she
cried during the procedure and they
charged her for it
shut the [ __ ] up because they have to
consult crying extra
it's like a tip
yeah that's like a [ __ ] tax
a [ __ ] tax
for me a little bit i'd be like can i
get the price i'd be like can i get the
price menu because what the [ __ ] i want
to know what if i'm gonna have to be
charged for crying i'm to hold in my
tears yeah i didn't know this yeah i
didn't know that maybe she didn't know
about the uh menu
she didn't know that you could look up
the prices and what they were going to
charge
i don't think any of us did they put her
under or something what's the procedure
brief
emotion
well what if you have like positive
emotion or no is that still brief
emotion charge i think it's her emotion
it's the surgeon's emotion all like he's
tired of your [ __ ]
maybe or crying like made him cry a
little bit even worse like he had a bad
day and he this is like a surge charge
because he's an empath yeah he's like
please don't cry oh [ __ ]
your energy
i have to do moon ritual tonight but
also is
is brief emotion worth 11
what's that's very subjective like price
like what's it what's it worth to you i
like how it's calculated though it's
like how long because like therapy is
like what two hundred or three hundred
dollars this might be a good price brief
emotion you just gotta get a mole well
like i'm giving you a discount
i'm hooking you up right now
i didn't even charge you for [ __ ] how
loud it was all right
it's terrible i gave you a discount yeah
so um what the [ __ ] is every other line
item what's all the other stuff surgical
services point one oh yeah they didn't
charge didn't charge it right no no
they're all zero zero zero it's the
physician services can i see the receipt
again yeah i don't know why they pointed
that out were they trying to just uh see
if they could hide the particular motion
in this
yeah they're all penny no they're 10
cents they're 10 cents 74 f 78 f 25 f
that's the line item for the menu it
seems like a [ __ ] invoice
like this is the weirdest invoice i've
ever seen but they discounted her two
dollars and 20 cents for the [ __ ]
brief emotions she sent the yelp reviews
it also looks like it was printed in a
newspaper
yeah yeah look she saved forty six
dollars though dude that's the paperclip
what is this classified ad personals but
why did she cry during the mole removal
i know i should be a little [ __ ]
because it hurt nick is that why because
people cry i get i [ __ ] tear up
during a coveted test when that [ __ ]
goes to my brain yeah that [ __ ] is
because she's saying goodbye to an old
friend yeah like an emotional attachment
yeah emol chanel
do that [ __ ]
so there was uh an addition to
the affordable care act including uh
this particular code called cpt code
96127
which allows uh medical providers to
charge for behavioral or emotional
assessments for reimbursement
isn't that something along the lines of
if someone's trying to attack you
or like
fight you
i think it's okay if someone's crying i
think mole removal is part of it
it's in the is it a loophole that that
was meant for something else that's just
mole
god dammit
i wish i could remove that joke
i wish i could [ __ ] charge you for my
emotional
drama dude like an [ __ ]
that's valid that's valid that's very
bad that is drunk that has standards and
that's going to be way more than what 43
oh yeah i felt that your vein popped out
[ __ ] no discounts dude ten percent on
[ __ ] yeah i don't know if you know this
it's compounding probably don't we've
been everyone collectively as a group
has been just railing on anthony
grossing the [ __ ] out of this because
he's the he's he's the most successful
this is so funny he has the most sex out
of all of us and you're welcome to take
shots as well he's the most stylish yeah
you can call him a blow job have her if
you want me like that he's a sex haver
yeah yeah [ __ ] have her for sure
woman pleaser yeah
so we get to [ __ ] on him because he's
all lowkey backhanded disses still no no
it's true
[Laughter]
no
anyways yeah emotional charge you'll get
you'll get an invoice from me soon and
you'll get a bill for all my crypto
services you piece of [ __ ]
so
that's what this is what's crazy about
this actually is that they're if you
ever get line items and all this
[ __ ] like you ever go to vegas and
you get resort fees and all [ __ ] oh dude
what the [ __ ] it's so true yeah they're
basically saying hey we just did this to
the affordable care act and now we can
start we found other ways we could bill
you while we help you save on medical
bill shit's the best man you gotta love
you gotta love it so she breaks even at
the end of it exactly uh so she's
confused obviously she uh and she shared
it with twitter we don't know uh where
she lives or any of that kind of stuff
she says that she lives in the
stratosphere so i guess she's kind of
funny
person she's pretty funny i didn't know
they couldn't or does she live in vegas
yeah the strategy where she could live
in the stratosphere in vegas i didn't
think of that yeah we want a lot of
money that time when we played crafts at
the stratosphere man that was nice well
and we were pissed too because we're
like damn we got to pay the 20 limit
tables and then we're wrecking that
table
you should have charged them for the
emotions if you're pissed that's true
damn are you okay buddy i'm [ __ ]
pissed
you need a hug huh i need your [ __ ]
receipt it's taking
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's gonna slit our throats later you
[ __ ] chipped away at his [ __ ] ego
too much man we gotta bring it back up
but when you're with us we gotta bring
him down because he's too successful man
yeah yeah
i got to keep him on the show you guys
got to keep doing this [ __ ]
you have too many streams of income
too many streams of income passive
income i know too much what a thing to
like criticize someone over we got to
knock that down a little bit i know
too successful none of them work
bring him down to our level so he stays
on jk
i love how yesterday he threatened us
because he brought this arcade machine
in he's like don't make me turn on the
quarters thing you have to pay quarters
another revenue stream dude
to know the version of what he really
said in here that's so [ __ ] yeah he's
like he's like oh yeah it's all free
play right now but guess what i could
change at the quarters you guys don't
mess with me too hard oh yeah
all right
all right he's [ __ ] these threats
right here
i'll pay your [ __ ] [ __ ] receipts
too [ __ ] receipts too what the [ __ ] is
that i got plenty of quarter saved up
because i have my i've had my own
laundry machine for years nowadays
it's not gonna keep me up at night at
all that's where the coin shortage ended
up it's just all in that bucket what was
with the coin shortage is it because
they don't want us to actually hand
money that's what i heard i heard that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] i heard it's because
uh
you know
they weren't making them
because of the the medals
it's too expensive medals like it costs
away [ __ ] more to make it i don't
think it's making a change piece of [ __ ]
metal well even that the labor and
everything because you know how like
they're printing money like crazy right
now
and then they're saying like yeah i
don't know so inflation [ __ ] them up
too so like to even make a quarter it
cost them like 30 cents now exactly yeah
oh my gosh
holy [ __ ] that's what they get why is
our government so stupid bro like god
they should just make orders out of
paper now i don't want to hand my money
to stupid people i'm stupid enough to
[ __ ] use this money why do why would
i give it to even stupider people that's
going to burn my money is that mom where
the camera slowly zooms in on joe's
monologue
[ __ ] government man why do i give him
why then you put dramatic music in the
background posting on facebook i don't
want to hand my money to stupid people
i'm stupid enough to [ __ ] use this
money why do why would i give it to even
stupider people that's going to burn my
money let's make this charge for
emotions bro yeah yeah
yeah promotion i should charge the
government for emotions [ __ ] playing
with my heart and [ __ ] what's your
feelings all the time dude telling me
you're gonna print out more money
oh dude i just saved all this [ __ ]
money for what
so you just give it to people just you
can gesture with it
you guys said i was pissed
you know what sucks about like [ __ ]
they're charging for that emotion [ __ ]
my friend who's a skid row dentist can't
even charge when they bite his hand what
and he doesn't have aids
does your friend have aids man
maybe from a previous unrelated
encounter but not from that dude you
everybody knows dogs have rabies
homeless people got aids they'll [ __ ]
bite you with it that's just their
[ __ ] vampire blood yeah you can't
like it's already they're already can't
pay you for the dentistry in the first
place
they're like trying to take out academy
and they're like
they just do random [ __ ] they just start
yelling in the middle of it for like it
gets skid row dentistry
i didn't even know there was a thing
dude something they get they gotta take
2000 and then sometimes they'll get bit
and there's nothing he can do he just
has to be like well got bit dude he
should wear hot gloves
spicy ass gloves no no the hot ones
hot sauce
like a home alone defense tactic are you
going to buy my hands
while you're doing dentistry
but then you put on the gloves you're
like oh they're boiling hot what did i
do
the hot gloves i did it goes into your
pores dude for sure it goes in your foot
no dude yeah get those [ __ ] hawk
gloves
like [ __ ] town they're talented oh
honestly if we're going to print out
money
we need to give it to people like ryan's
friend
getting bit by homeless people that's
where we should get getting aids bro
that's what that's what dentists do to
relieve some of their debt from school
as they do they [ __ ] fix homeless
people too they'll do skid row dentistry
for like several years and these whole
school guys shares you know what these
homeless people got insurance
that's the whole thing they probably you
do it yeah you do it to like you're like
servicing the community and how do they
pay their debt that way uh
they'll forgive your debt to do it for
so many years it's like a really a crazy
program whoa
well i guess for a 300 000 dentist
school debt yeah yeah so that might be
worth it yeah let's take [ __ ] take a
few homeless bites
watch out
do you just randomly start chomping i
guess so
i mean what most of the [ __ ] that is
happening with mentally ill people is
safely to say random yeah
yeah it's not but it's not guaranteed to
all have mental illness but for sure all
of them have aids
watch out dude
it's just no joke man i mean if you're
getting your hand bit during a dentistry
thing premeditated or not it's still the
same result
aids
you don't even have to go get checked
you just go get aids treatments
immediately skip hiv that whole thing
just goes right to aids huh yeah if
you're lucky it's just
rabies
and you still can't charge nope nope
because you signed up for it boo
so that's what you signed up for
joe's in vegas right now
bruh
[Music]
you